with the black pieces Liam has made his
first move here we go now it's a queen's
Pawn opening Liam tends to start the
game this way and we do see a Queen's
Gambit declined while not taking that
pawn on C4 and we see Magnus adopt the
triangle formation as black as we said
as as we call it this uh setup of horns
in the middle of the board Rock Solid
but Liam tries to go for a Catalan type
of setup against it this is a bit risky
because it does involve a four Pawn
sacrifice which Magnus accepts Ivanka
risk taking from both sides so far they
are definitely and incidentally this is
a very similar approach to the one that
Liam Lee took against the ancest of Duda
yesterday when he won that important
game with the black pieces and uh Magnus
preserving that extra pawn and this is
why Liam has to generate some counter
play and jumps in with the Knight to the
center attacking the C6 pawn and Magnus
he's just on the defensive right now he
defends that pawn and a very intriguing
battle ahead this is quite a trendy line
and white certainly does have
compensation and often doesn't even
bother trying to win back the pawn just
says have it and I will just develop my
pieces put them on good squares and
create a bind to suffocate the black
pieces yeah white is significantly ahead
as well in development right now white
is the first to Castle black is still
three moves away from ever castling his
King and uh White's light Square Bishop
perfectly placed exerting some serious
pressure whites night perfectly
centralized too I did see Magnus just
before he pushed his Pawn to B5 he was
looking out the window again he was just
like what have I prepared here and then
he played a couple of moves now he's
thinking again I wouldn't be surprised
if he looks out the window to the left
oh he's slightly looking to his left and
uh just above the screen here and there
we go he looks again off to the left
because for sure he studied this but uh
every human needs a few seconds to
recall what they've looked at in the
past he might have studied this maybe
six months one year even five years ago
it's just about what what set up black
wants to choose black has a lot of
options the good thing about having no
developed pieces is you can develop them
all in a bunch of different orders
expecting one of the two black knights
to develop now not sure which one
and once Magnus decides once he starts
activating then it will be up to Liam to
prove that he has compensation
for the pawn yep I can tell you the most
popular move is the one that Magnus has
played it's actually possible to just
develop the other night as you say and
just return the sacrifice material and
Liam is paying in a very ambitious way
he's just like okay fine I'm gonna
accept that I'm going to be a pawn down
but take a look at what species they are
in commanding positions and it's not
going to be easy for black to develop
and it's certainly not going to be easy
to break out that light Square Bishop
yep black slides called Bishop it's a
target for some of the white pieces
certainly and uh yeah black still needs
to Castle and I have to ask you this
question I mean can is one one question
but should black capture that pawn in
the Middle with a queen because that
feels like it's poisoned and it feels
like maybe the computer gives it's a
blessing but why does it feel like it's
poisoned
there's a lot of time to take this Pawn
so black is already one Pawn up you
could make an argument for just being
satisfied with one Pawn you could move
the bishop out the way then try to
Castle and say okay I'm gonna pull up oh
that's enough for me but if you're
really really a maximalist which a lot
of the top players are they will want to
go two pawns up because that's a
significant Advantage you also attack
this rook in the corner you attack this
white knight in the middle white can
deal with that in a very simple way you
just move your Bishop you attack the
black queen and now the black queen has
to run away to safety
um I think I've seen a game in the quite
recently uh where black moves to Queen
across I think that was Iranian against
shankland in the recent us Championship
or at least it was very similar to this
position offering a queen exchange but
for example if the queen were to retreat
let's say she goes the whole way back
you've basically lost two moves as black
you've taken this pawn and then you've
retreated back where you came from and
you give white two moves so you've given
white a bishop development move for free
you give white another move now for
example white could use this to develop
his rook and white would gain two moves
for free so yes you you've won a pawn
but is it really worth it
um that's like the Eternal question in
chess do you want time or do you want
material and uh Magnus decides he wants
the material he wants the time rather
than the material he moves his Bishop
getting ready to Castle and the M says
okay you didn't take my Pawn that time
now I'm gonna move
daring you to take my Pawn but this time
it would looks even more dangerous
um if Queen takes porn Here Ivanka I'm
already looking for sacrifices that
white can play for example taking this
Pawn with a knight hoping to blow open
this diagonal for the white bishop and
if Black's Queen steps back to capture
then white has a few tempting moves but
at the minimum you can just move the
bishop because uh just to show off here
if the queen moves uh then a knight
would jump in with a nasty Fork winning
the game and if the queen even takes
this Knight then after a queen trade
white is a whole piece and two pawns
down uh two pieces and two points down
even but you can regain one of them now
and you trap this rook in the corner for
next move yeah Magnus says no no way I'm
not touching that pawn and instead it
reinforces his uh born on B5 and uh Liam
finally defends the pawn on D4 yeah so
he's protected his center now Magnus
does have time Magnus will most likely
just castle and it will be up to Liam to
prove that his active pieces White's
great pieces that they do compensate for
the one Pawn I'm expecting Liam for
example to either gain space in the
center or put some pressure on Black's
Pawn formation on this left side of the
board there's lots of different
alternatives for white I have to tell
you a thousand out of a thousand times I
would have taken that pawn with the
black queen both two moves ago and in
the previous move is that a typical like
beginner's move yeah
um maybe it would be a typical mistake
for a lot of players not just at the
beginner level but even quite
experienced players if we do go back
especially one move especially here we
would say okay we can take a pawn we're
attacking the White Knight we gain time
against White's night but unfortunately
we have to just back everything up with
calculation nowadays in chess and if you
don't develop your pieces if you're not
quick enough to Castle they do say you
should always castle by move 12 if you
don't Castle then you might often get
punished so uh so yeah it's not
necessarily a mistake to capture this
Pawn but you have to double check that
there's no immediate consequence that
there's no way for your opponent to
punish you for losing time being greedy
and yeah I've made that mistake as well
countless times in the past Kaya and
that's made me scared now of capturing
pawns so I've gone the opposite way I'm
I'm a bit of a coward when it comes to
losing time and Magnus okay he didn't
Castle very surprising he uh he didn't
grab the pawn of course but now he just
moves his Queen across the whole idea is
to protect this light squared Bishop
meaning that at some point for example
if white is too slow that black can push
upon break out the whole idea is to try
and trade off White's great light
squared Bishop very intriguing Choice
actually because I just have one game in
my database and it's a very interesting
game actually it was played between
Oscar Idol and Alex Balin and Oscar Idol
is rated 1722 and he beats someone 400
points higher rated than himself wow in
this particular position and he did that
by moving I think the bishop out to the
A3 square that would be a very logical
move now that Black's Queen has
abandoned the dark squares white can
actually prevent black from castling at
least temporarily now black cannot
Castle because the bishop on E7 would be
under Fire And if you trade off those
Bishops those dark Squad Bishops then
suddenly after the White Queen
recaptures
the White Queen has x-ray vision and you
can't Castle through track so Black's
King is still stuck in the middle and
yeah maybe this would be a bit
uncomfortable for Magnus to deal with
maybe a small consequence of Black's
last move and I have to say I'm looking
ahead at the way that Oscar Idol played
and it was very impressive you know the
Rooks just came to the open line and
very natural play
[Music]
it looks great for white just
aesthetically you have two great Knights
you have this Superior Bishop White's
Bishop is the kind of active piece
Black's Bishop is the passive one White
Queen far superior to the black queen
White's Rooks already uh in the center
who needs a pawn when you can have great
pieces
so this is the move we're expecting from
White right now in the current position
we're expecting Liam to develop with
gain of time and he would prevent Magnus
from achieving his number one goal to
Castle
yeah dangerous position for the world
champion and will he play it what do you
think I think he will after a bit of
thought and this is a bit of a theme as
well so Magnus he's on fire he's winning
all these games but it's a bit of a
theme in the opening it's never that
impressive especially against Anish giri
yesterday Magnus was significantly worse
out of every game in the opening but he
always turns it around it's the middle
game that he's uh putting his stamp on
and okay he doesn't develop that
direction he goes the other way with the
white Bishop I also want to say eight
wins in a row uh I'm trying to recall
any time that's happened at the top
level ever I mean the one kind of
biggest run that we talk about is
Carolina winning seven in a row in the
sync fuel Cup in 2014 and that's kind of
gone down in history as the biggest kind
of winning streak that eight in a
Roadhouse yeah incredible it's a very
impressive I mean what I'm thinking of
also is uh magnus's run and the Julius
bear preliminaries where there he got 12
out of 15 points so maybe he won eight
in a row then but uh I don't know about
eight in a row against some of the
world's finest players in a head-to-head
match that's incredible unheard of if
you ask me and there we see Liam putting
his Rook on an open line
but uh somehow
I don't feel that Magnus is being
challenged as much I mean it's still
very complicated position for Magnus but
he can get his King to safety
I think he should as soon as possible
he's he's used to Darling at Magnus he
likes to kind of postpone castling often
prioritizing development or exchanges or
Pawn structure but
this type of position it is about to
explode it's kind of a breaking point
now the climax is building and you need
to just run away you need to play it
safe I would be costly in a heartbeat so
I don't think I would even pause for
that I mean one thing I have to say for
the black position is black is a pawn up
that's uh stating the obvious but he can
return some of the material so for
instance the C6 pawn and once that pawn
disappears well Black's pieces get a lot
more freedom and we might see a
situation where White's Advantage which
was primarily due to the pressure on
this Pawn has just dissipated and the
position is equal yeah so you're talking
about this porn Ivanka and this is a big
Target for example if Magnus castles I
think white can pretty much win that
pawn immediately as you mentioned let's
say there's an exchange maybe black can
capture a different way but let's say
whites Knight jumps into the center and
now it's pretty much guaranteed you win
this poor next move no matter what but
uh even if uh okay let's say black
pushes forward I think there's other
ways to do this but even if white cat
and regain that pawn just to prove your
point here I think black is okay Black's
Rook will just slide across and pieces
are disappearing yes this is a dangerous
passport but it will be blockaded and
can white really aim to push the
advantage even further now
I'm not so sure I think suddenly all of
the activity in White's position is
compensated for by the fact that black
is Rock Solid White's night is a bit
loose white the black Bishop is about to
Sprint to life
don't think Liam should be greedy you're
right so I think that's what Magna
should be aiming for giving back a pawn
just to alleviate the pressure and uh
going back this is the current position
what else can you consider other than
castling it just looks so natural it
just looks so safe
I think most humans would have played it
instantly he spent two minutes Magnus
down six minutes on the Block the only
other move that I can think of is
actually attacking the bishop
um and uh the whole idea is that after
Bishop takes Knight if it captures then
maybe I would even consider Pawn takes
and uh trying to resolve the tension
that way but Magnus has had enough he
wants to get his King to safety he's
just run through the lines and checking
that it's all okay and uh now I guess
Liam is working through those captures
that we talked about yeah so Liam could
trade off at night a set of nights here
he could trade off Bishop for night he
could maybe move this Knight out the way
at some point because he really wants to
open up his rook's vision towards the
black queen but
I haven't yet seen an effective way the
computer does indicate that white does
perhaps have something quite strong here
but I'm struggling to see it I must
admit white has the advantage but how
that is the question it would be this
move yeah it might well be this movie
and uh the whole idea is that Knight
takes night is of course met by Bishop
takes Bishop yeah this bishop no longer
protected I really didn't like that
Queen Shuffle that Magnus played a few
moves ago it just feels like the queen
has a clear Target on the C8 square and
she no longer protects this piece on E7
suddenly yep the black Rook can indeed
move but once the white Bishop runs away
to safety uh suddenly black has a
problem with this Knight has a problem
along this whole diagonal to be honest
and uh again look at the white pieces
especially the queen and Rooks so active
compare them to Black's Queen and Rooks
not great pieces at all so yeah it looks
like Liam has found the way the most
accurate and most direct way to seize an
advantage there's already threats now on
this C6 Square uh with the white Rook
the white knight in the middle and the
white from afar so I'm watching out for
that pawn to just disappear and the
question then will be whether Magnus can
equalize once the material levels out
definitely a successful opening for
white for Liam maybe a comeback that
would be huge if Liam Leia is able to
win this game he has so much more time
on the clock Liam
and he does capture the knights I must
admit I thought that this wouldn't
happen and we're going to see Bishop
takes Bishop on the board and the
position they you're like our resident
fortune teller David
will you stay here on the analysis board
tends to occur in real life okay the
bishop is going to go all the way back
normally I'm saying don't play this it's
a mistake and then the players they go
for for it and uh I mean I can't blame
Magnus for capturing that night to be
honest I would have been reluctant
because again I'm biased towards the two
Bishops suddenly white has the bishop
pair but uh yeah maybe he had to and
Magnus is a much lower on the clock
right now so he's in a spot of time
trouble he needs to make those quick
decisions and at least now the position
is starting to clarify there will be a
bunch of Trades I just think White's
Bishop is going to return yes you can
maybe grab the C6 Pawn if you leave the
white Dart score Bishop 187 you take the
Black Knight in the middle instead but
unless you're kind of forcing a win
there I would be reluctant to cash in I
think now might not be the moment to
cash in I have to say we have detected
one tiny floor in Liam's lays position
game and that is he does force things in
critical moments we saw that against
Duda when he he sport a win he just like
lashed out and we also saw that yeah
mainly in his match against Duda and in
general but uh I I think he is looking
at that capture yeah
I have a feeling he'll choose the most
direct path as well you'll write your
Banker a few years ago just before the
virus struck just before in 2019 I
played in St Louis I played Liam in two
matches in two games uh classical chess
and okay he does play a direct move and
I noticed as well in both of those games
he was outplaying me and just at the
moment where he should take a step off
the accelerator and just slowly maneuver
then he kind of broke through and just
forced to draw so oh he could have just
kept the pressure he doesn't like the
tension necessarily and wow there has
been a big transition because just like
the last game
one of the queens has been sacrificed
and this time it's magnus's Queen and
Magnus is going to try and build a
fortress it's like a mirror image of the
previous game we have to jump in Black
now is material down uh so this is the
current position but if we jump back
Liam didn't spend much time before
cashing in on the material taking this
Pawn now the White Knight had to be
captured it's too strong and after
Bishop takes Knight using this pin white
is winning material so uh Bishop takes
Bishop happened the black queen dropped
off the board and if we do a quick count
here just like the last game it's queen
versus rook and Knight
hear this more elements to the position
there's opposite color Bishops it's not
clear who that favors I like Black's
Bishop in the middle of the board for
now but there's also an imbalance
important structure so black has two
versus one on this left side
what do you think ivanko this shouldn't
be a fortress either
it should not be a fortress but then
again I did say that and I will I came
to eat my words in the game that Magnus
played against Wesley where he blundered
his queen and I was like there's no way
this is a fortress too many holes in the
black position and it was a fortress
um here I agree with you the presence of
the opposite color Bishops seems to me
that uh White has the upper hand and I
definitely think it should be winning
I'm going to put the odds on about 65
percent okay
I've been known for my optimistic
percentages and it's not just that it's
winning but uh also it's that black is
the one fighting for the draw fighting
for his life a black win here is nearly
out of the question already because the
White Queen uh she should be able to
hold against any uh setup of pieces and
the evaluation bar reacts this looks
like a very nice move by Magnus he looks
like he's about to bring his Knight into
some decent outposts but could it be uh
just a mirror image again of that
previous game where getting active with
the Knight is not actually the best path
maybe keeping it passive keeping it as a
defensive piece which would have saved
Liam in game one today maybe that was
magnus's best bet
better what is the idea now I guess
Magnus is banking on the fact that if
the White Queen moves for example to
capture this Pawn the Black Knight will
indeed get active there's no time to
take this bishop because of Queen takes
Knight and exchanges will help white
here White's ahead of material so
bringing the Knight forward I think this
is magnus's idea and when the bishop
moves to safety for example the Black
Knight could create some counter play
suddenly attacking this Rook attacking
this pawn and uh yeah White's not
completely safe here
so what is the computer wanting to play
it gives a huge advantage to white but
Magnus still has chances to hold a
fortress later on this is the current
position I'm expecting the bishop to
just Retreat somehow and uh Liam he
shouldn't be too direct anymore I think
this is where he should take his foot
off and say okay I've won material I've
done the hard work I'm going to slowly
step forward so for example bring the
bishop back if the white knight if the
Black Knight moves slowly push this Pawn
slowly push the Central Pawn slowly
bring the white king towards the center
yeah I don't think you need to be uh
going straight for the kill anymore I
agree with you and the one poor move
that I would never make in a million
years is actually to push the e-born
forward if I did that I concede all the
light squares to Black and suddenly that
Bishop becomes a Monster yeah yeah this
would be a strong piece so let's see
what the players have in store yeah Liam
he has so much time on the clock again
is he making a comeback winning this
game Magnus Crossing with an uh eight
game winning streak maybe losing now and
we're gonna go to San Francisco to Tanya
what's going on Tanya
just a lot of fun here Gaia I mean
Magnus just seems Unstoppable as
Christopher mentioned himself just so
impressed with his play now while in
there in the playing Arena we've got our
players fighting it out I've got
Christopher and a very special guest
Allison here with us Christopher will be
trying out the Ace in the sleeve game
he's already up to level four uh
Christopher are you ready for the
challenge yes Magnus caught 39 on this
so you just have to beat his car
I I yeah I'm not sure I haven't gotten
to level 4 yet I'm still on level three
but after I finish level three we'll get
to level four sure so while he gives
this app a try and tells us how well he
does it how much fun he's having we've
got Alison here with us who also is
Christopher's childhood friend uh she's
also somebody who's doing a lot of cool
stuff here for the chess Community fem
chess is her not-for-profit organization
Alison welcome to the show thank you for
having me so thumb chess is a non-profit
youth-led organization and what we do is
we hold online classes for
underprivileged girls so all of our
classes right now are online and we have
about 50 different
um students and 20 different coaches in
a variety of 10 or so levels and uh
Christopher you is our chest advisor who
has gone over our curriculum and has
kindly revised it to make it the best it
can be that just is such a cool
initiative I want to ask you what is
your vision with fam chess
um our goal is to bridge the chess
gender gap and especially enable
underprivileged girls to learn more
chess because as we know chess is a very
expensive sport so with private coaches
100 200 an hour and some people they
just like don't have the mean to do that
so we want to provide that free coaching
for them to be able to learn that chess
and do you find a lot of interest in the
community amongst girls to take part in
this yes I find that girls really really
like learning chess but then it feels
like kind of a social stigma of like
guys are more expected to play chess but
then girls it's um kind of harder for
them to get into the sport because
they're just surrounded by men so we
want to um change that and enable more
girls to learn chess how do you bring a
change about in that so just slowly by
slowly right now we have around 50
students so we're just
uh coaching them every step of the way
every week we hold one hour classes and
slowly but surely they're improving and
they can start competing soon so yeah
so yeah and do they feel more
comfortable uh with chest and more
confident with their ability to be able
to play in open tournaments as well with
this program yes so actually most of our
students are beginners but we actually
do have several that are competing
already so our goal is to get all of our
students to be able to start competing
and be comfortable in a tournament
environment that's so cool and you feel
very strongly about this we were
chatting earlier and it's so nice to see
that you're really involved in this yes
I feel very passionate about this
because I was really fortunate to be
able to afford private coaching so now I
just want to give back to the community
that's helped me so much especially like
my mentors on my first coach like Joseph
Lonsdale and then Judith's story and
Abel talamentes who was the former
director of MI super nice here and we
wish you all the best for your for fem
chess and the vision that you have
meanwhile we've got Christopher back
here with us how did you do
I'm about to try level four so let's go
take a look did you have fun are you
having fun with this I'm having an
awesome time
is it tough
it's you know it's not it's not too
difficult yet but I'm sure it's gonna
get extremely difficult the farther you
get
all right well we've got Christopher you
here trying out Ace in the sleeve
um and I see he's struggling a little
bit with this one we will report back
and let you know how he did back to you
guys in the studio so I'm already
getting more difficult
as Tanya told us earlier she has tested
this game we have to mention Magnus
played it at level 12. uh the Ace in the
sleeve game which is a game within the
Magnus chess Academy app that you can
now download on iOS
and Tanya was able to beat Magnus who
had a score of 39 cards and we are
asking you guys as well to share us your
results take a screenshot how are you
doing you have to start on level one and
make your way towards level 12 and level
12 is where you have three minutes to
solve as many cards as possible that's
where mine has had a result of 39 cards
but share with us your results and maybe
what level you are struggling with
Magnus is right now struggling in this
game against Liam
is Leah making a comeback do you think
David yes it does look like white is in
full control Magnus is struggling big
time now and it's all to do with Liam's
plan he's clearly learned from that
previous game where he was playing
against the queen now he has the Queen
and he's simply trying to open up lines
towards the black king I love Liam's
last move pushing the white g-pawn
forward I think he's going to push that
white G Pawn even further over the next
few moves and trying if he can to break
through on the king side
do you see any drawing chances here
um Blackness it's really dependent on
what Liam does this is uh the thing I
think Magnus is purely in a reactionary
mood and there you see the queen slide
over and she starts eyeing up the King
on the right
um all magnets can do I think is hold
tight hold the fort and just to
anticipate what Magnus sorry what Liam
is going to do so Liam clearly
indicating that he's gonna push the H
Pawn perhaps uh two squares forward to
H4 and then to H5 and then maybe the
yeah I'm gonna get very optimistic with
what Liam has planned there on the right
but uh Magnus just has to battened
batten down the hatches yeah I don't
think Liam's even going to play it that
slowly Ivanka I think he's just going to
forget about pushing the white h-born
he's just going to push the G Pawn open
up one line that's all he needs against
the black king the white Rook can swing
across to the G file opposite the black
king as long as you get one open file
towards it this is where you need your
Queens black has no Queen to defend
Black's Knight is on the other side of
the board where are the defensive pieces
around the black king Magnus in I mean
huge danger right now of just getting
steamrollered wow for the next four or
five moves could be his first uh lost
then Magnus in the tournament after now
winning eight games in a row and
actually after winning the first game
today Magnus reached a new record rating
on the mouth or the Champions chess tour
2903 is his current tour rating that's
just insane but if he loses this game I
think he's gonna go back down under 2
900 probably so he needs to enjoy it
while it lasts yeah and uh he loves
those ratings he loves the numbers they
really motivate him that'll be
disappointing he'll want to keep this
winning streak going as long as he can
it's not every day you get a chance to
win a ninth game in a row but uh yeah
this one I think he's just thinking
about saving
because already it is that desperate and
a long think from him as well he's down
at just over three minutes against eight
now
so it's the clock the board the pieces
everything's against the world number
one he brings his Bishop back to the
center he's just waiting yeah
I mean really it's difficult to suggest
a move for Magnus I have to say it just
has to wait for the lines to get opened
and then
use a rook on the horizontal to defend I
don't see anything else to be honest
we'll hope that he can have enough
defensive resources to at least prolong
at least delay White's attack enough for
him to get counter play there we go Liam
is just going Brute Force straight for
the black king and Magnus surely can't
capture this Pawn it's a bit surprising
to me that Magnus even put that black H
Pawn on H6 a few moves ago that's
created a hook this is what we mean
white pushes his Pawn forward and using
the black hook the black Pawn on H6 he's
just gonna break open the position and
he's just going to tear open some lines
and it feels like you have to block it
up you have to block up as many lines
towards the black king as possible uh I
just don't see anything else if you take
this Pawn White's Queen will recapture
and White's Queen is going to give
Checkmate within a few moves yeah it's
that simple at the moment yeah the big
problem though for Magnus is that if he
steps up with a pawn then okay we see
Magnus trade the night his or his bishop
and uh if the Pope I was just gonna say
if if you step up with the H porn the G
Pawn is going to be doing an demolition
job on the black king side I mean it's
going to take a step one square forward
yeah for example it will sacrifice its
own life just to open up a file I don't
think you can allow this Pawn to exist
if you kind of bypass it then later
white screen is just going to sneak over
grab this pawn and use the white G6 Pawn
to deliver some mating threats this
would be terminal takes a few moves but
it's game over
and if you do capture as you say Ivanka
if you do take this Pawn now White's
Rook will switch directions you could
switch with the queen as well and
breaking through
this Pawn is just dropping you can
defend it with the King but now the
White Queen adds the pressure and you
can say goodbye to this game because
White's Queen Rook together
are overpowering that lone black king I
just don't see any way to save it this
is the current position how do you keep
the lines closed
I mean it feels like the G file is just
is the way in white only has one way in
but it's enough no Fortress here
too many pieces as well to hope for a
fortress if the if there was a rook
trade then maybe black could hope to
hold if it's just a queen alone that
you're fighting against but a queen of
Rook together is too much okay Magnus
takes and pushes a pawn you're right
earlier he's going to try and defend
across the board horizontally so for
example if the queen steps forward he's
going to use his Rook to try and defend
this Pawn
but yeah it doesn't feel like it should
be enough not only can white Switch his
Rook at the right moment but he can also
start pushing up on
this is going to act as a battering ram
yeah and uh well he doesn't actually
step forward with the Rook instead he
grabs material just uh going for that
philosophy well you know if you're
suffering you might as well
suffer with some extra material yeah so
at least Magnus has some some hope of
counter play he needs three moves to
really create a threat but can he
survive three moves Liam has three or
four moves to deliver Checkmate and he's
going for it now swings The Rook across
the black Rook moves the White Queen
takes a pawn using this pin the White
Queen cannot be captured uh so Black's
Rook shuffles across as well
and all white needs to do is step back
step somewhere safe with this queen yeah
yes she should protect her Pawn on C5
and then after that well there's a pawn
that's not working okay he attacks the
bishop ice also quite like this one and
then I was just going to say there's a
pawn that's not working the H Pawn and
let's push that one up the board after
grabbing material first yeah why not
grab material now he's taken all this
thing out of Black's pawns this Pawn
alone won't do any damage I think we
might see Magnus resign soon because as
you mentioned later Ivanka this Pawn is
going to kill the game this Pawn is
going to open up the black king
Magnus he'll try and survive but the
king is too open the black piece is not
coordinated
the final stages wow just everything
going wrong for him in this game we're
only at moves 34 35 now yeah full
credits Liam he got a great opening but
a lot of players in the in this
tournament they've got great openings
against Magnus but they haven't finished
it off or they've let things turn around
or they played too passively he's gone
straight for the kill and we mentioned
that his one weakness maybe Lim is being
direct but it can also be a great
strength being direct and especially
against someone like Magnus before he
gets balanced before he gets control
yeah it feels like Liam struck just at
the right moment and Magnus had no
answer
and he's closing it out really nicely
very calmly as well not rushing
that means this match will be tied after
Magnus won the first game with two rapid
games to go will we see a winner in the
rapid poison or will it go to Blitz tie
breaks
we also see the other games action is
happening between Prague and Duda Duda
won the first game and in the second one
Prague sitting in San Francisco the bar
has been over to the young Indian side
for big parts of the game but now I see
it's in the middle so it is that gonna
be a draw what do you think there's a
lot of life left in that one between
Prague and Duda I still quite like
prague's chances but uh dude as he
always does uh he's escaped a bit he's
uh he's very slippery lucky he's very
hot yeah I want to use the word lucky
but he he makes his own luck he's very
hard to pin down
uh I think anyone looking to defend
losing positions should study his games
because he's good at creating practical
chances tricking the opponent and it's
going to be such good news for him if
Magnus loses this game against Liam lair
giving Duda a chance to maybe catch up
with Magnus on the standings if Magnus
loses today's match and Duda wins as
much in the rapid portion I'm also
noticing Geary or a guy see Gary lost
the first game today sitting in San
Francisco and the bar is basically
saying that he's losing another one
against Arjun yes and that one should be
over quite soon imagine is winning a
rook and Pauline game and I think in
quite a simple manner he's just got a
couple of extra pawns there uh yeah Gary
just it's been a downhill few days for
him he started the tournament so well
the thing is uh he Gary seems to be in a
pensive mood you know I was looking back
at some of the older interviews and even
after he won his game against his match
against Liam Lee in the very first round
he did kind of mention that he didn't
necessarily enjoy playing chess but he
did enjoy winning uh-huh and I wonder
whether that's a source of the problem
as well he's just not relaxed enough
when he's actually performing he's uh
you know he enjoys the result of course
but there's too much tension when he's
playing chess
some things are pretty scary struggling
but we have seen earlier in the tour
finals a huge comeback from him after
losing two games against Prague he did
win two rapid games and he won the match
in tie break so it's still possible for
Anish giri Wesley so he won the first
game today against chakrian Mahmoud
yarov and the bar is over to his side in
game two as well could go up by two
points Wesley so Mama Dr was struggling
playing at night in Azerbaijan not the
best time for him to play chess
is sitting at home in St Louis it's a
good time for him to play chess the bar
has gone slightly down but is he still
winning this game against Magnus he
should be I think until we see either
that black porn create some serious
counter play by running down the board
or maybe an exchange of Rooks then then
perhaps Magnus has some chances but
until we see that happen it feels like
it's all about the black king Liam's
idea at least it's very human he's
lifted his Rook up the board he's going
to swing that Rook across just one
square to the right to the H file he's
going to step it behind the White Queen
and try to head for some checkmating
ideas if he can support the queen
coordinate those two pieces together
then it should be game over but uh the
computer thinks Magnus might have some
chances to defend now I think from a
human's point of view though when you're
down at two minutes when you're facing a
queen so many countless threats almost
so yeah it's going to be too much to
handle yeah but you know it's Magnus and
I suspect that his only hope lies in
pushing that B Pawn and me whereas if we
look at Liam's plan it kind of involves
a trade of Rooks if he's going to
capture that GG Pawn
okay I don't think he's going to bother
with pawns I think he wants to check
mate yeah yeah
but yes the problem is how does the
black I mean maybe at some point we'll
see the black king start running towards
the center how to the black kings stay
safe behind its own pawns simply Rook H3
the white Rook shifting across one
square that's going to create some
diabolical threats yeah I did miss that
when the king runs over the queen does
have a chicken Square on d8 yeah I'm
already struggling to find a defense for
Magnus Magnus clearly struggling to
define the defense as well under two
minutes now let's just show the threat
so for example black here okay he moves
his Rook across what is the idea so for
example if you push push this Pawn then
Rook H3 does create almost Unstoppable
chat meeting ideas you can't even run
now as you mentioned Ivanka just because
uh if the king starts running this would
end the game immediately and uh okay
this is on the cards now Liam has
created a checkmating threat he has
shuffled his Rook across so the idea is
Queen to h8 into the corner trapping the
king
Magnus he has to move his Rook he cannot
move his King he has to move his Rook
somewhere just to create an escape
Square for his King I'm not sure whether
you step up the board maybe you step
across
you have to run away you have to flee as
fast as possible with the black king
I mean that's the only thing you can do
you have to move this Rook remember King
f8 falls into immediate checkmate
we've seen Prague blunder intermittent
one I don't think we'll see Magnus do
the same
so okay he has to move his rock out the
way this is the square the king wants to
use
he steps back okay so at least now he
can run
still feels like it's teetering on the
edge
yeah it feels so shaky as anything and
the queen comes and gives check King
runs and I'm suspecting The Rook will
move one square to the G3 Square attack
the born on G7 and
Max Brooks will be so passive yeah if
black has to put his Rook on this Square
just to defend then it's not going to be
uh Happy Days for Magnus white can start
pushing this Pawn forward for example
um yeah plenty of ways to win this game
surely one passive Rook means you will
never have counter play
yeah and Liam does indeed Shuffle his
Rook across and this one yeah I think
now we can say Liam is a heavy favorite
to convert it shouldn't take too much
longer could be a huge result this for
the tour finals Magnus losing this game
if he ends up losing the match then
anything can happen with uh two days to
go it's gonna be a fun weekend here in
the tour finals no matter what Magnus
after this match still has Prague left
tomorrow and he's going to finish off
against Duda on the very final day and
imagine if whoever wins that final match
due to Magnus is the winner of the tour
finals that is the dream scenario of
course
yeah absolutely I can't wait for that
mat up because traditionally magnuses
had their upper hand when he plays Duda
but in the last tournament the aimed
chess rapid it was Duda that knocked
Magnus out that's true yeah yeah he's on
great form yeah and uh there comes the
age porn it's two squares away from its
destination and Magnus just has to
retreat the Rogue
um the F5 Rook put it on F6 just curl up
in the smallest ball possible and start
praying
he's got to pray to all the gods here
because uh yeah it's just hopeless it's
beyond hopeless at this point you just
need a trick and White's moves are just
so straightforward
that's what we talk about in chess
sometimes we can see the evaluation bar
clearly on white side and unless there's
a massive blunder it will stay that way
it's not the type of position where uh
if white doesn't find the best move
every time it will immediately drop this
is the type of position where it's gonna
stay in White's favor for a long time
and as Ivanka mentioned the black Rook
drops back the White's Queen is now free
to retreat and maybe change angles
attack and looking good yeah he had
Wesley so looking over his shoulder
there Magnus Carls and it's another win
for Wesley against Muhammad yarov so now
with only a draw in game three with the
white pieces Wesley will win that match
same situation for our guysi he only
needs a draw in game three against Geary
to win the match this one
if and I think maybe I can say now when
Magnus loses this match will definitely
go to four games we are in for a lot of
action between Liam Lee and Magnus
Carlson today
13 12 seconds 10 seconds and then and
the world champion has terrible position
six seconds five four Let's Make a Move
Magnus they lose on time no no oh he
makes that move with two seconds left
and that's often a Telltale sign that's
a giveaway that Magnus is struggling
when he's this low on the clock
um it's normally because the game has
been going against him the whole time or
there's too many options and here
there's a lot of options for black of
course but they're all losing and he
attacks the White Queen the White Queen
can Retreat anywhere along the diagonal
any safe Square
um I think just plant it in the middle
of the board does she have to move there
is a tactic on the board don't even have
to move here that's the move that I
would instinctively would play I
wouldn't even think I would just pick up
my rook and capture the pawn on G7 yeah
take this pawn and he doesn't go for it
but this would have been a nice way to
win this would have been a check and
after The Rook has captured the other
Rook is no longer protected and uh
you've won a pawn in the process maybe
Liam just wanted to keep a set of Rooks
on the board but this would have been a
killer the H Pawn now would be passed
and it would be about to promote so this
would have ended the game pretty much
instead of taking this Pawn he dropped
back to the center I I saw this one as
well I thought oh this looks good but
Magnus now he's reacted by pushing to G5
so he's hoping that any checks can be
met by the black king moving
but uh on passant as well it's legal you
can take this Pawn
and I do wonder whether Liam will have a
chuckle when that move is when that move
was played primarily because Duda did
this to him as well yeah so it's an
unexpected unexpected move and uh it's
unfortunately just like in the game with
Duda you know it was unsatisfactory but
it has good surprise value Rick takes
Pawn on the board yeah I was going to
say you can be flashy here and Liam is
flashy he takes this pawn and uh the
whole idea is now there's a check and
when the king moves you'll pick up one
of the two black Brooks no matter what
and the King does Shuffle across and it
hides out in the corner so finally you
find a safe square and you've traded one
set of Rooks but unfortunately white
does have potential for a second pass
Pawn these two are going to start
marching and here we go one of them
steps forward the other one's going to
join now if these two white pawns didn't
exist maybe you have some chances to
draw but
uh that we see on magnus's camera
there's no chance now Black's Rook is
all also just paralyzed it's stuck
you're playing without a rook he even
gives up his Central Pawn just to free
that piece but white can take it white
has three past pawns and this will be
enough to win the game I think we'll see
Magnus resign any moment now white will
take that pawn with a lot of pleasure
and it's going to be game over
Queen takes porn queen give a check
anything can be played and so you can
remember how to resign though it's been
a long time since he lost the game not
since not in this tournament I think
it's been a month since he lost a game
yeah maybe since he lost a Duda uh
uh in the last tournament or maybe in
the Fisher random uh World Championship
that's the last time you lost
true
and uh he's just going through the
motions he's forcing Liam to show that
he knows how to win but yeah
unfortunately here everything wins
so a couple of checks and then we will
see white pick off that pawn in the
middle
and that is basically the the end that
is the death bell yeah it's gonna ring
and uh well oh look at Liam he doesn't
even bother capturing that pawn instead
he just walks his King over to the
action
that is nice yeah it's unnecessary you
could have just taken that board for
free pretty much but he has the idea of
maybe trying to Checkmate and in order
to Checkmate remember you can't use a
queen alone you need the support of
other pieces often that's your own King
in the end game so the white king will
close the door it will cover the Escape
squares of the black king and then the
White Queen will try to sneak behind and
deliver Checkmate for example if the
White Queen can somehow get to the h8
square in the corner from behind that
black king is trapped and there we see
the evaluation bar does react and this
is a mating net the black king has no
Safe Haven to hide on anymore
and there we go Magnus does finally
admit defeat losing his first game in
the tour finals Magnus Carlsen is now
tied with Liam Leia this is such an
important